- Yeah, so my name is Nneoma Adaku.
I'm currently a fifth-year MD-PhD student
in what we call the
Tri-Institutional MD-PhD Program.
So we're kind of a mix
of three different biomedical
research institutions
on the Upper East side.
So I'm currently working
on my PhD at Rockefeller,
where I'm studying melanoma metastasis.
So I'll talk to you guys today
about what is cancer metastasis
and how we actually
figure it out in the lab.
And then after I'm done with my PhD,
hopefully next year or so,
I'll go back to med school
and finish at Weill Cornell,
which is across the street,
and I'll finish my last two
years of medical school.
And then the goal is kind of
finishing medical training,
so you still have to do like
residency and fellowship
and all these other things.
And at the end,
when there's time for Q and A,
if you guys wanna ask me
about like the career path,
I'll be happy to do that.
And then, yeah, the goal is to
become a physician-scientist,
see patients,
while at the same time having a lab
where I'm actually studying the things
that my patients are experiencing.
And kind of in terms of
like non-career things,
so I'm originally from the Bronx.
So I don't know if we have
any Bronx people here,
so I was originally from there,
and then I lived for
a few years in Atlanta
before going to undergrad at Yale.
And I know you guys
attend like an early college, high school,
so actually did a very similar thing.
In high school, I did a
dual enrollment program,
where I lived two years
on a college campus
before going to Yale and
doing four years there,
and then really wanted
to come back to New York,
so I chose this program,
and now I'm here.
And when I'm not doing school things,
I mean, my hobbies are like,
I like to bike around
the city, play soccer,
pre-pandemic, going to concerts and stuff.
And now more so in the
house playing video games
more than anything else, at this point.
So, yeah.
So maybe we can get started with a poll
just to get a feel of the group.
So for me this is a very crucial question.
So if you guys could only eat one food
for the rest of your life,
would you rather do pizza or tacos?
See, this is how I know
it's a New York group.
It's mostly pizza that's
winning (chuckles).
All right, so it seems like
a pretty strong consensus, pizza.
I do agree with that.
You get a pretty balanced meal with pizza.
You know, you get your
carbs, you get dairy,
you get your vegetables.
If you're a meat eater, you
can put some meat on there too.
But I feel like tacos are
kind of cleaner to eat.
So if I had to do it
for the rest of my life,
maybe tacos would feel
less heavy to do every day,
but I could go either way.
All right.
Thanks, guys.
So, yeah, as I'm going
through like the lesson,
feel free to interrupt me, ask questions.
Pizza for lunch. Yes, go for it.
Definitely feel free to interrupt me,
ask questions at any point.
And at the end,
again, I'll try to leave in a space
for Q and A and everything,
whether you wanna ask about the science
or my path in life in general, feel free.
All right, so I'm gonna share.
So I'm gonna be drawing things in Paint.
All right, so, as I mentioned today,
I'm gonna be talking to you
guys about cancer metastasis.
So, you know, in our bodies,
there's kind of a...
Let's see if this is gonna
start drawing or not.
I think I'm gonna have to use my finger.
Okay, there it is.
Yeah, so in our bodies there's
kind of a constant balance
between cell growth and cell death.
So here I'm kind of just drawing...
If you were to look at your
skin under a microscope,
you would see you kind of
a nice balance of cells
that kind of grow up from the bottom.
We call it basement membrane,
which is down here.
And then as they grow up
in layers, they die off.
So when it's dried out like now,
you're kind of ashy,
that's all those dead skin
cells that are coming off.
So there's a balance between
these cells at the bottom
that have the grow,
and the cells at the top that have to die.
So if you lose this balance,
then you can just keep
growing these cells,
and maybe you'd be walking around
with six inches of skin,
which would not be very good to live with.
So this is what's happening in our bodies
every day in every tissue.
There's a constant balance
between cells that are dying
and cells that are growing in
order to maintain our tissue.
So what happens in cancer?
I'm just gonna make a new one here.
So in cancer, instead of
having this nice, flat,
even layer of cells,
you got a cell that kind of
goes wild and keeps growing,
disrupts all the nice
even architecture we have,
and then keeps growing.
And that's what we call a tumor.
And how does this imbalance
happen in that cell?
So what happens is that a cell
has to take on what we call it a mutation.
So here's an individual cell,
and we're just gonna simplify
its DNA in the nucleus here.
So what has to happen for
a cell to become cancerous
and start growing crazy and never dying,
is it has to have these
mutations in its genome,
and that's DNA that turns off a gene
that stopped cell growth.
And that's what we call
a tumor suppressor.
So tumor suppressor is a gene that,
when it functions normally,
stops yourselves from growing too crazily.
So when you have any mutation
in a tumor suppressor,
then the cell kind of...
You're kind of cutting
the brakes on that cell
and it's able to keep growing,
even at the conditions
normally it wouldn't be
right for it to grow.
But you have to be unlucky
to also get a mutation,
and what we call an oncogene.
So I'm just gonna try to write this out.
So an oncogene is a gene
that makes a cell grow,
and in normal conditions,
it's not always on,
because, again, you don't
want the cells in your body
to be constantly growing.
But if you're unlucky
enough to get a mutation
in both a tumor suppressor
and an oncogene,
then the cell has no
limitations to its growth.
So you're basically both cutting to breaks
and putting a brick on the gas,
and the cancer cell just
takes off and forms a tumor.
So I'm gonna ask you
guys another question.
And you don't have to know
the answer by any means,
but what do you guys think
can be a source of oncogenic
or cancerous mutations?
So what are things that
can cause these mutations
in a cell to happen?
And choose as many as you think.
So maybe I'll give you guys a minute or so
- About 60% voted.
We're waiting about 30% of the vote.
You won't know if he got it wrong.
Just throwing that out there.
- Yeah, don't feel shy
about putting the wrong answer.
Okay, so that's a pretty good percentage.
So I'll just end at 80%.
All right, so almost all
of you chose radiation,
so, exactly, that's kind of
one of the strongest sources
of mutations.
So, basically, radiation,
what it does is that
it's super high energy,
and it just hits your DNA and
like breaks it pretty much.
So your cells try to put
together your DNA to fix it,
but sometimes it makes mistakes.
And that way,
you can get mutations
that could hit an oncogene
or a tumor suppressor.
Infections, some of you
also voted for that.
And that's also correct.
So there are certain viruses
and certain bacteria that,
when they're left untreated,
can lead to cancer by
causing, again, mutations.
So one example is HPV,
which causes cervical cancer.
So that's why we have this HPV vaccine now
that they call a cancer
prevention vaccine,
because it really does do
that by preventing HPV.
Another example of a bacteria
that could do this is called H. pylori.
So it's bacteria that infects your stomach
and causes ulcers.
And then over time, as
that infection continues,
you can develop gastric
cancer, stomach cancer.
A lot of you guys chose
being born with one,
so very good.
So it is possible to
be born with a mutation
in one of these genes.
So an example of that you may
have heard of is called BRCA.
That was one thing that
Angelina Jolie had,
and she got what we call
a preventative mastectomy.
So she surgically removed her breasts
to prevent the chance of
her getting breast cancer,
because she was born with
a mutation in the gene
that could increase your chances
of getting breast cancer,
as well as ovarian cancer.
So very few of you chose oxygen,
and that's kind of a trick question,
but actually oxygen can cause cancers.
So what happens in our
cells is that oxygen
can cause these things
called free radicals.
And our body has a system in
order to kind of clear oxygen
that kind of changes its structure
and can destroy or affect our DNA.
So when you're actively breathing oxygen,
like, no, that's not gonna
instantly give you cancer,
but if the process within your cell
can no longer clear these free radicals,
then it can lead to cancer.
And some of you guys chose 5G network.
It actually doesn't cause cancer.
It's just your normal wireless network.
So I know there are probably
a lot of conspiracy theories
out there about 5G,
but 5G does not cause cancer,
so don't worry about that.
All right.
And, you know, as you grow older,
the chances of getting
mutations like this increase.
So that's why most people
with cancer tend to be older,
just over time there's
more and more chances
of you to acquire these
kinds of mutations.
Just gonna make a new canvas again.
So if you have a tumor
that's forming in your skin, for example,
as long as it stays there in the skin,
it's pretty harmless,
because there's nothing really around.
So if you had a tumor in your arm,
there's not really anything around there
that it can affect much.
So the problem is when these
tumors start to metastasize.
So I'm again gonna draw my skin here.
And now my cancer is forming.
So over the course of years and years,
this tumor is developing
and growing bigger.
And then eventually a few
of the cells in the tumor
leave the skin and actually
enter the bloodstream.
And once these cells enter the bloodstream
and kind of look around the body
and see, oh, what would
be a nice environment
for me to go into it and stick around in,
that's when we have a
problem called metastasis.
For example,
say these cancer cells go around
and then they find the lung,
and they think, hey, it looks
like a pretty good place
for me to go.
So they, once again,
exit the bloodstream,
and travel to the tissue of the lung.
And then there they
form yet another tumor.
And this is what we actually
call the metastasis.
So a metastasis is a cancer
that has left a primary site,
so the primary site being
this part of the skin here.
It traveled all over the
body and found and organ,
a new home for itself to grow in.
And so this is actually
what kills the majority
of cancer patients.
So 90% of cancer patients
die when their tumor
goes to an organ like the
lung, the brain, the liver,
and grows there,
and starts affecting the ability
of that organ to function.
So when you can no longer breathe,
when you can no longer perform tasks
when your brain or your liver
can no longer clear toxins
because there's tumors growing in it,
that's how patients
tend to die from cancer.
So our lab is really trying to figure out
what causes these cells to
like change their behavior
and be able to survive
in a completely different environment
from where they started.
And every step of this pathway,
from leaving the primary site,
to entering the bloodstream,
to leaving the bloodstream,
to like finding a new organ
and growing in the organ,
there's only a small percentage of cells
that can survive each of these steps.
So I'll have another
question for you guys.
And, again, you don't
have to be right at all.
So just take a guess.
What percentage of cells that
you think are able to make it
from a bloodstream to actually
forming this metastasis?
So like what percentage
of cells make it from here
to actually doing this at the end?
Again, I'll give it
another 15 seconds or so.
Yeah, I'm just seeing the chat now.
And you guys talking
about pineapple on pizza.
I didn't do it either.
Okay, so almost all of
you voted, so that's good.
All right. So let's go through.
So the majority of you guys voted 10%,
which is a very logical guess.
It seems like small enough,
but also you would think cells
that have already made it this far,
they can probably make it towards the end.
But the actual answer is 0.01%,
which is 1/10000.
So only 1/10000 of all the cells
make it to the bloodstream.
And, again, that's already
a very small percentage
of the cells that actually
leave the main tumor.
Only one of 10,000 of them
are actually capable of going to the lung,
or whatever organ,
and growing again there.
So, you know, cancer is a constant battle
of like evolution and numbers.
You know, the numbers of cells
that can actually form the metastases
is very, very small,
and they have to somehow
evolve a number of techniques
in order to make it to the end.
And so, again, that's kind of what our...
Wait, I forgot to share.
I don't know if you guys
can see the answer. Yeah.
So that's, again, what our lab
is kind of trying to figure out,
how these cells are able to
pick up like little tricks
and techniques in order
to actually make it
to the end of the metastatic
cascade, as we call it.
Okay, so I'm gonna demonstrate to you guys
how we actually study this in the lab.
And to really study this process in a way
that could be most informative,
we have to develop a system
that mimics kind of all these steps
of both having the primary tumor,
and then tumor cells
that are able to get into the bloodstream,
and then make it to a different organ.
So basically what immunofluorescence is,
it's a way of using
antibodies in order to amplify
a certain thing that you want to look out.
So assuming these are all
cancer cells this time,
these cancer cells have certain proteins
on their surface that are unique to them.
Again, since they're coming from a place
that isn't normal in the lung,
so it's like coming from the
skin instead of the lung,
these cells look different
than most of the cells of the lung.
And we can take advantage of that
to actually find the specific cancer cells
that are in the lung.
So to do this,
we use antibodies that can
identify these special proteins
on the cancer cells.
So, yeah, these are antibodies,
and then we use another antibody,
called the secondary antibody,
that has a tag on it.
So just gonna use a different color here,
and this tag is fluorescent,
so it basically glows.
And then we can use a microscope
in order to basically shoot a laser at...
Oops, accidentally stopped sharing.
So this microscope can shoot...
Let's see, I wanna change the color.
So this microscope shoots a laser
and it turns on this glowing fluorescence,
then that fluorescence goes
back to the microscope,
and it's able to show you
where the antibody's
bound to the cancer cells.
So to do that, basically,
we cut up the lungs into these slides,
and then we add on the
antibodies and everything
in a process,
and after about a day or so,
then when we're ready
to actually look at them
under the microscope.
So I'm actually in the room
now with the microscope.
So I'm gonna show you guys.
This is our big microscope.
So this is actually where you look in.
Actually, the part where you look at in
is way smaller compared
to like the whole thing,
which basically takes up this entire room.
And then once you wanna save the pictures
that we see in the microscope,
then we have a computer here
that saves the pictures.
How much do you guys
think that microscope is?
So when I heard it, I was shocked.
So you can just guess in the...
And while you guys are
guessing how much it costs,
I'll answer these questions
about how do we slice them so thin.
So there's a machine called the microtome
that you pretty much put the...
It's kind of like those meat slicers,
if you've ever seen
like a deli meat slicer,
it just makes those
like really thin slices,
and the machine just like cuts it.
It's kind of similar thing.
So you can like program the machine
to tell it how thin we
want the slices to be,
and then put the lung in there,
and it cuts the lungs.
And in terms of the orientation,
it doesn't really matter unless...
'Cause usually whoever's doing it
kind of places them in the same way.
If you wanna look at a
certain part of the lung,
then it is important to like
make sure you're orienting it
in the machine,
so that you can get the
part of the lung you want.
- [Ms. Mason] Is the lung
encased in something harder?
Oh, okay.
Then they're squishing under a blade.
- Yeah, yeah.
After I took the lungs out and
put them in tubes like this,
then we do a process
called paraffin embedding.
So we basically put
them in this kind of...
I don't know what the
most similar to like...
Kind of a wax,
basically a wax mold.
And then from that you
can cut through the wax
and take some lung with it as well.
So you guys have made some good guesses.
So the highest was $800,000.
I just spoiled it, sorry, guys (laughs).
The highest is $100,000.
It actually cost $800,000
just for that microscope.
So it's very expensive to do the science,
and we spent a lot of money to
like figure these things out,
and every time I come here,
I'm scared that I'm gonna break it,
because that'd be my whole,
entire life's earnings, basically.
Yeah, so I'm gonna show
you guys an example
of a picture that we get
at the end of this process.
And then we can do a bit
of Q and A at the end.
So this is a picture I took
recently with that microscope.
And you see the glowing.
So I'm just gonna let it play,
and then actually pause it
at kind of the main part.
So this is me kind of going up and down
through the section
in order get the full dimensions
of the tumor in the lung.
So I'll just pause it here.
So, basically, in order to do this.
So as I mentioned,
we used these antibodies,
in this case, it's glowing green,
the cancer cells.
We also need is a stain called DAPI,
that just stains every cell in the lung.
So it's not specific,
but it kind of lets us know
that wherever we see green,
we know it's real,
because there's also a nucleus,
or a blue dye with that green,
because, you know, for example like here,
it's possible to just
have a bunch of green,
but it's not actually a cell,
because there's no nucleus
associated with it.
So this is kind of how,
even though I can't see this tumor by eye,
by using a microscope that can go
from 10 times stronger than my eye
to up to 100 times stronger than my eye,
I can actually see in
these lungs now the tumors.
And I'll do another picture
that kind of zooms in more.
So this is at 40x,
so 40 times stronger than my eye.
And now you can see the
actual individual cells
pretty clearly.
So like this one's a pretty good one.
Again, this green signifies
that it's a cancer cell.
And then since there's blue in the middle,
I know that it's a real cancer cell
and not just the antibody going wherever.
So maybe there's like one
more minute for questions,
but if you guys have anything else
you wanted to ask...
I can also put my email in the chat
if you wanted to ask about,
you know, science or why
I chose to do an MD-PhD.
- [Ms. Mason] I would love to hear about
why you chose the MD-PhD.
- Yeah, for sure.
- It seems to be really hard.
- I was actually in high school as well
when I kind of learned
about the MD-PhD process.
So like in school,
I just always loved science
more than any other subjects,
and biology specifically.
And my mom was a nurse,
so she had like these anatomy books
that I would look at,
and things like that.
And I would watch like medical
documentaries or whatever.
So I was like, okay, I really,
really wanna be a doctor,
but also really like the
discovery aspect of science.
And I liked watching
or like seeing like science documentaries
and like hearing scientists talk about
how they discovered this thing,
or like the cellular process,
or like how this...
So I basically liked most aspects.
I liked the idea of like
working with patients
and like learning about the
human body and everything,
but I also like the idea of being a person
who like discovers certain
things that nobody knows yet.
So I felt conflicted,
so I was like, "Should I be a doctor?
Or should I be a scientist?"
So then I kind of like,
just Googling what are
different career paths
in science, whatever.
Then I like stumbled upon MD-PhD,
and like learned that it's
actually possible to do both.
You can get an MD and
like go to med school
to become a doctor,
but you can also get a PhD
and like learn how to be a scientist,
and there are programs
that integrate that,
so that you can pretty much
become a physician-scientist
who like sees your patients
and like goes to lab and
studies the same things
that your patients are being affected by.
And I liked being able to both
have that immediate impact
with like actually working with people,
and like giving them therapies,
and like speaking with them one-on-one,
but also liked kind of
the long-term impact
that doing the research would have.
So like in 10, 20 years,
like the research I'm doing might actually
have an effect on
patients in the long-term.
So that's kind of why
I decided to do MD-PhD.
It is a long process.
So medical school normally is four years.
And then you go on to
residency and fellowship,
which was more training
after medical school.
And the MD-PhD program is eight years,
so pretty much double the time,
because you have to fit in that PhD.
So if you were to do them separately,
if you were to do an MD,
and decided, oh, I
actually wanna get a PhD,
a PhD is on average like six years now.
So if we were to do them separately,
it'd be like 10 years.
So like doing an MD-PhD
program does shorten it,
but it's still like a long time,
but one benefit is that,
again, they're like integrated.
So they're really teaching you career-wise
how can you do these both as a career,
become a physician-scientist,
and also they pay for med school
and they give you a stipend.
So I don't think about it
as eight years of school.
I think about it I'm doing the job,
'cause I'm getting paid.
So that's how I look at it.
So yeah.
- [Ms. Mason] Any last
questions from kids for Nneoma?
I wanna make sure to be
respectful of your time.
I think you said 40 minutes
and we're past that mark,
but we'll follow up if
anyone has burning questions
to ask you.
- Yeah, again,
feel free to email me.
I'm happy to talk.
This was like the stage
where I really learned about MD-PhD,
and I think it really helped me
going college already knowing about it,
and helping me make decisions
in terms of what to do.
So feel free to email me,
or Ms. Mason, feel free
to email me as well
and relay things to your students.
And I'd be happy to talk more about it,
but thank you guys.
I hope this was really helpful.